foreign
tastic video on how to become a devops
developer by simply learn but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these type
of videos and find them interesting
subscribe to our YouTube channel as we
bring you the best videos daily also hit
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply learn so let's get started
and typical organization the development
team creates products and the operation
team manages and maintain these products
however the devops concept is
collaboration between development and
operation tips which enables continuous
delivery of applications and services to
the end users
this means that when the development
team is ready with the product it goes
to the maintenance and management phase
immediately and is released to the end
users with a minimum delay according to
information week devops will be the
highest demand in the future with little
chance of slowing down the devops market
will be worth USD 14.9 billion by 2026
and the average salary of a devops
developer in the US is 112 000 and in
India it's seven lakh per annum a good
sign that demand will remain
consistently high but before we explore
how to become a devops engineer we need
to address the question
which certification course covers all
the necessary skills to become devops
developer your answer is here if you are
an aspiring engineer or professional
look no further than our Celtic post
schedules program in devops devops
training course design and collaboration
with Caltech ctme is a professional
development option that will Square your
skills with industry standards our
cutting has Blended learning combines
live online devops certification classes
with interactive Labs that will give you
hands-on experience our devops course
and certification will bring you out
scientists in you you will learn how to
formalize and document development
processes and creating self-documenting
system this devops training course will
also cover Advanced tools like puppets
salt suck and ansible that help
self-governments and Automotive
management at skill for admission to
this postgresage program in devops
candidate should have prior work
experiences not mandatory a bachelor
degree with an average of 50 or higher
marks can be from a programming or
non-programming background for more
details check out the course link from
the description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
devops developer a devops developer is
an IIT professional with an in-depth
understanding of the software
development cycle they need to
understand why the organization had to
move from one model to other the
shortcomings of the previous model the
benefits of the new model and so on so
this is why the devops is here a devops
developer must also know how to use
wages automation tools for developing
continuous integration and continuous
deployment CI CD pipelines this demand
position requires a unique set of devops
skills which we explore more in depth
later so before let's see devops
developer roles and responsibilities a
devops developer roles and
responsibility combine Technical and
management root it is essential to have
excellent communication and technical
skills to successfully integrate various
function in coordinate Manner and
deliver the responsibilities to the
customer satisfaction here are some of
the code responsibilities of the devops
developer first one is understanding
customer requirements and project kpis
the second one is implementing various
development testing automation tools
third one is managing stakeholders and
external interfaces fourth one is
setting up tools and required
infrastructure fifth one is have the
technical skills to review verify and
validate the software code developed in
the project and the next one is
mentoring and guiding the team members
and the next is monitoring and measuring
customer experience and kpis and the
last one is managing periodic reporting
on the progress of the management and
the customer so next moving forward
let's see devops developer skills a
devops developer rules require technical
skills in the development cycle and the
operation skills for the maintenance and
support computer science or computer
technology graduates can bring some of
the technical skills necessary to become
a devops developer however the skills
required for managing the operation
usually comes through experience or by
enrolling in specific development
program which can help further the
career in the set Direction you can
check the course link for the
description box below the first one is
experience working on Linux based
infrastructure this indicates that the
individual has practical Hands-On lab
with Linux operating system they are
likely familiar with tasks such as
server provisioning system
administration and maintenance on Linux
server this experience can be invaluable
when working in server heavy environment
the second one is excellent
understanding of Ruby python Pearl and
Java having an excellent understanding
of these programming languages that the
person is proficient in writing
debugging and maintaining code in
multiple languages this skill set can be
crucial for various tasks including
scripting Automation and software
development the third one is
configuration and managing databases
such as MySQL mongodb this point implies
that the individual is skilled in
setting up configuring and managing
databases specifically monitoring MySQL
and mongodb they can handle tasks
related to database Administration
optimization and potentially even data
modeling the fourth one is excellent
troubleshooting excellent
troubleshooting skills are essential in
any it or software related role it means
the person can identify and resolve
issues efficiently minimizing downtime
and disruption troubleshooting can
Encompass many problem from software
bugs to Hardware failures the fifth one
is working knowledge of various tools
open source Technologies and cloud
services this indicates that the
individual has familiarity with broad
spectrum of tools and Technologies they
will likely have experience with open
source software and cloud services which
are prevalent in modern ID environments
this adaptability suggests they can work
with variety of text tag the sixth one
is awareness of critical Concept in
devops and agile principles devops and
agile are modern software development
and project management methodologies
awareness of critical Concept in these
areas implies that the person understand
the importance of collaboration
Automation and iterative development
they likely know how to integrate
development and operation teams to
streamline software delivery in summary
a person with these qualification and
skills would be well suited for the
roles that involves managing and
maintaining liners-based infrastructure
handling various programming tasks
configuring and managing databases
troubleshooting technical issues working
with wide array of tools and
Technologies and understanding key
Concept in devops and agile
methodologies such skills are highly
valuable in today's IIT and software
development landscape with that we have
come to end of this video on how to
become devops developer I hope you found
it valuable and entertaining please ask
any question about the topics covered in
this video in the comments box below our
expert will assist you in addressing
your problem thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you